snacks coming at 12 o'clock.
Gentleman.
There you go! Thank you.
look at the baby soda sponsor!
Alec, shut the heck up!
''laughter''
Once you begin to discover who you are... then you really realize how you have been given authority over your life!
... but you can only do that through the struggle of life.
And most people avoid the struggle. Most people go through life avoiding pain!
When you're working on a dream, at some point in time a transition takes place...
you learn how to live higher!
You start challenging yourself to dig deeper.
something in you that you never activated is lying dormant in there.
don't try and take any shortcuts!
do what you know is right!
You've been chosen for this great work!
''I don't know man... you ever just feel like life is just pushing us towards something...
like some greater purpose?''